Hattie Joan a PhD student at the
University of Montreal and Mila has set
out to understand and explain the
performance of modern neural networks
believing it to be a key factor in
building better more trusted models
having previously worked as a data
scientist at Uber a private Equity
Analyst at radar capital and an economic
consultant at Cornerstone research she's
recently released a paper in
collaboration with the Google brain team
titled teaching algorithmic reasoning
via in-context learning now in this work
Hattie identifies and examines four key
stages for successfully teaching
algorithmic reasoning to large language
models formulating algorithms as skills
teaching multiple skills simultaneously
teaching how to combine skills and
finally teaching how to use skills as
tools now through the application of
algorithmic prompting Hattie has
achieved remarkable results with an
order of magnitude error reduction on
some tasks compared to the best
available baselines now this
breakthrough demonstrates algorithmic
promptings viability as an approach for
teaching algorithmic reasoning to large
language models and may have implica
stations for other tasks requiring a
similar reasoning capabilities anyway I
hope you enjoy this conversation that I
had with Hattie over at nurips a couple
of weeks ago enjoy amazing well um
Hattie we're here at neuros yes welcome
to mlst
you uh please introduce yourself
um I'm Hattie Jo I'm currently a PhD
student at Mila and
part-time researcher at Google brain
right now as well as student researcher
so yeah fantastic and I've been reading
your paper teaching algorithmic
reasoning via in context learning
give us the elevator pitch
the elevator pitched so I think
typically in the past people have
thought that large language models are
not great at doing symbol manipulation
or actually doing reasoning the way
humans do and uh common example people
point to
for this failure is to show that models
can't even do addition properly even
though it's trained on you know billions
of tokens like billions of parameters
um and in this paper we try to teach the
model how to solve these problems by
learning an algorithm for them and see
if it can generalize to harder problems
generalized at a distribution which is
like a common way to see if the model is
actually using the correct algorithm to
solve these tasks so it's not just like
fitting to the training distribution and
finding experience features it's
actually
executing an algorithm so we do that
through some prompting strategies and
show that actually can learn how to do
addition contrary to previous belief
yeah I wanted to speak about the
previous belief so um with large
language models I'm vacillated back and
forth from being skeptical and being
very optimistic I was originally very
skeptical and I'm becoming more
optimistic as time goes on I interviewed
a lady from UC Irvine called yazaman
rosegi and she did a really interesting
bit of work actually kind of comparing
the term frequencies as they appeared in
the Corpus to the um you know arithmetic
as a number of um you know as a function
of the number of digits and um because
open AI Never released their data set
statistics so it wasn't possible to do
that and she found that there was like a
linear correlation but I think what's
really interesting now in in your work
and some of the the other work like um
uh you know chain of uh prompts
um chain of thoughts prompting and
scratch Pad prompting that now we're in
this new regime where we're kind of
telling the language model it's almost
like we're treating the language model a
bit like a kind of compiler and we're
giving it the program and then it's
actually extract appellating and it's
doing things that it wasn't you know
directly taught
that's the first
refer
to
you can give the model a program you
'll see that the model can
use that program and apply it to new
situations and so
that's kind of the reasoning out of
distribution component but I think also
ideally you can imagine we want the
model to be able to discover algorithms
that we don't know ourselves and you
know that's a whole other Frontier right
but but this is the first step to on
that path I think okay well why don't we
start by defining algorithmic reasoning
sure so
I think about it as just the way you
solve a task is by using a particular
algorithm
and algorithms are input independent
which means that basically for any input
distribution using that same algorithm
will get you the right answer and so
performing reasoning
um by running an algorithm is what we
refer to as algorithmic reasoning and of
course these right now applied to tasks
that can be solved by an algorithm
but you could also Imagine like cases
where you have a soft algorithm where
the steps are not so rigidly defined but
there is the overarching
problem like solving structure that you
can follow yeah could you refer to that
I mean maybe I I would refer to that as
like inductive algorithmic reasoning so
it's where
so on one side of the spectrum you you
actually have the algorithm and you
write every single step explicitly using
some kind of code and now we're talking
about this regime where we are giving
examples of an algorithm and we're
describing the steps somewhat vaguely
when we're trying to be as clear as
possible using language so where are we
kind of following on that continuum
well let's say you take a algorithm of
addition
um
but you're actually so you have an
algorithm defined where you like start
by taking the first digit do something
with it and then get an answer and then
move on to the next one
um
when I think about a soft algorithm it
can look something like that except you
take the digit and the something you do
with it is not defined explicitly but it
might require some abstract uh
pattern matching the large language
models are particular to that so it can
use the same process of breaking down
the problem in a very specific way to
generalize but the individual steps are
not actually
encoded in code because it's abstract
um
so if you can do that then you can use
this approach to tackle tasks where you
can't write an operator you can't write
a program for and that's like very
exciting I think can you give me an
example of where we can't explicitly
write the algorithm for something
well it you know it's hard to come up
with a good example because it's
supposed to be abstract in some sense
but
these will not be questions of uh
that you would normally tackle with by
writing a program so like it could be a
soft reasoning
maybe like
I guess maybe even the grade school math
word problems there is no algorithm or a
simple algorithm at least that you can
write that will solve like math word
problems yeah which I like you know if I
you have four apples I gave you twice
the amount of apples you have how many
do you have now yeah
um but if you define a way to tackle
these questions at each individual step
the model can decide like how to apply
that flexibly based on a particular
question
um
yeah that that might be a good thing to
to have
so but yeah right now I don't know
there is no good Benchmark for these
kind of things okay yeah and in your
paper so you came up with a new
algorithmic prompting technique and and
you you designed some experiments and
and your Technique worked significantly
better than some of the other income tax
prompting techniques okay can you sketch
that out for us yeah so the intuition is
simple actually when we look at the
addition algorithm the one that we learn
in school
um
we know that you know you start with the
rightmost digit you add enough you add
them up if it's greater than 10 you have
a carry of one and then you add the
carry to the next sum and so forth
um so a scratch Pad like approach
for addition we'll show the the trays
from running this algorithm so it will
show the first sum is this the carry is
this but it doesn't explain how those
values are derived but for us it feels
really natural because we're so familiar
with it but for a model trying to infer
the rules from seeing a couple examples
of it that's a very underspecified
problem right there are many rules that
could explain perfectly these
observations
so
algorithmic prompting basically explains
the each step of an algorithm using some
examples and within each step tries to
be as detailed as possible and tries to
disambiguate as much as possible what
you want the model to do and it turns
out that when you provide more details
to the model your sort of constraining
the model's interpretation of this
information so that there's only one way
to apply this
and that with that you can get more
robust behavior from the model and uh
you know reason very well out of
distribution
yeah because it's often said that
um deep learning models do not reason
and I think what people mean by that is
that you get this phenomenon of shortcut
learning and models do the right things
for the wrong reasons and it seems to me
that what we're doing here is is by
imputing the kind of the structure of
how to reason into the proms we're
robustifying Its Behavior out of
distribution yeah well said this exactly
right
fascinating so what what do you think of
this problem of shortcut learning in in
general because you know like it's
Melanie Mitchell said there are two
modes of understanding essentially
there's we we have this anthropomorphic
mode of understanding which is using
causality and it's very sample efficient
and we have a way of understanding the
world and we have a bit of an intuition
that large language models don't reason
the way that we do but is it necessarily
a problem and is it cheating in your
View using in context learning or do you
think that because we haven't had to
train the model again what's the problem
right I mean is it
is it an issue
yeah I mean I guess there's many forms
of reasoning and algorithmic reasoning
is only a subset of that
um
and I think if the model can
output the reasoning process and show
that the answer that arrives at is
following the output of that process
then it's hard to argue that it's not
doing reasoning right it might worked
differently under the hood but it
follows a similar process now you know
some methods
um you output a rationale but the final
answer is actually different from what
the explanations suggests it should be
and maybe you can point to that and say
oh the model isn't actually using this
it's just like giving you something that
you asked for but then the final answer
is still using a shortcut
um but with the algorithmic reasoning we
see that that's not the case and so
Yeah the more you constrain things maybe
the more
you remove shortcuts from the the model
um but an interesting question I think
is you can get this Behavior using in
context learning yeah which I thank you
I suspect you can't really do from
fine-tuning or some sort of weight
training I think when you do that you'll
most likely just overfit on the training
distribution I I wanted to ask you to do
you know it's a bit of an open-ended
question to say what's going on inside
large language models but what's so
exciting to me is that you get all of
this emergent strange Behavior no one
would have imagined five years ago that
we could do all of this prompt
engineering on a kind of Auto aggressive
language decoder and the model is trying
to do something really quite trivial yet
as a byproduct of all of this crazy
stuff emerges in its internal
representation and all of this
algorithmic reasoning capability seems
to be like a side effect of that
training
how does that even happen
oh that's a good question
um
it's possible that in order to fit that
large training data set the pre-training
data set
um you have to find
regularities in
content I guess that humans generates
and
I think some of these abilities come out
of those regularities that you learn so
the ability to
um
refer to the pattern of a previous
passage in in context and
you know
see what the relationships are in that
pattern and apply the same relationship
to a new input
um that circuit I think it's just very
useful as a way to summarize that large
data set and so
because you're forced to compress all
that data into a model a set of ways I
think these regularities
emerge somehow I don't know exactly how
um but I think
yeah the
I mean this is an interesting
speculation because then you can say
with much larger models where there is
no capacity constraint at all
and you fit all like
the same data sets it's not going to
learn very interesting Behavior because
it's able to just fit the model without
like capturing the underlying patterns
um and maybe that's why you actually
need more training data and training
longer rather than like the optimal
scaling is not right now in the model
size the amount of data because you want
like the right bottleneck for uh your
representation and I think maybe that's
where these
um
emergent capabilities are coming from
interesting yeah and and also the the
amount of training as well as the amount
of data um
I wondered what what is your intuition
on the Practical kind of computational
limitations of large language models so
at the moment they're trained with
Transformers and there have been some
pretty cool critiques of connectionism
by foda and um a few other people and
and it's basically along the lines of
neural networks can't represent infinite
objects which kind of distinguishes them
from Turing machines so they can't
compute the nth digit of pi is is a
fairly good example but the amazing
thing is that we're doing all of this
stuff with algorithmic reasoning and we
haven't found a ceiling yet it's just
getting better and better and I think
it's almost creating this
um
well I mean I'm I'm becoming quite
hopeful actually because I don't know
where the limit is but I suspect there
is a limit quite soon how do you think
about what the realistic computational
limits are
I think
the fact that now we have in context
learning is interesting because
that allows us to have
I guess adaptive amount of computation
and so if you have let's say you have
infinite context length
then you can sort of you know maybe do
infinite computation in that case right
um now is infinite context lens possible
probably not but then you can find
clever ways to distill that information
you can find like clever attention
mechanisms
and so I think
maybe there's a computational limit but
you can always like find new ideas that
make existing methods more efficient and
so
yeah I have no idea when you would hit
that limit but it's probably very far
into the future amazing and um so Hattie
we're here at nurits what have you taken
from the conference so far and what are
you most excited about you know going
forwards
um
yeah I know I don't know because I
haven't checked out the posters very
much yet but
uh I'm excited for the math AI Workshop
uh which you know is many other papers
exploring this idea of doing math with
language models yeah and uh yeah there's
some
you know very very impressive work there
um so I'm excited for that I'm excited
to meet people and see what they're
thinking about
and
maybe get some ideas for
what to work on next yeah I'm also
really interested in the math stuff I
spent about an hour speak speaking with
Marcus is it Marcus Bob who works on the
Christian spaghetti I think he's in your
in your group yeah they're doing some
that's right yeah they're doing some
really interesting stuff with um
basically doing mathematical
conjecturing uh you know like
representing mathematical expressions in
large language models and being able to
generate new ones it's the kind of thing
that you again would think was science
fiction five years ago and like
remarkably it works exactly and then by
the way with the mathematical
conjecturing Marcus was saying that
unlike with large language models it
only has to be right one in a hundred
times because they can formally verify
it so um it's almost like the the bar is
actually lower in that sense right yeah
I mean that's where the language models
informal reasonability is really useful
right
yeah like the pattern matching is
actually useful in a lot in a lot of
cases that's really cool cool well um
actually this has been amazing thank you
so much for coming on the show and
telling us about your research oh thanks
for having me yeah it was fun
looking beautiful uh she's beautiful so
uh Marcus it's so nice to meet you
um can you introduce yourself
hi uh I'm Marcus I I work for a Google
research uh together with Christian
Sergey in the interformal team um uh
generally we're working on uh um trying
to solve math
um
um basically by
trying to translate
um natural language mathematics into
formal mathematics and uh in in in these
former representations mathematics we
can
um check proofs and use that as a
feedback signal for the understanding of
mathematics and most recently I've been
working on Long context models like the
memorizing Transformer trying to get
these models
um like makes models sensitive to the
exact definitions and other lemmas that
that they might use for they're
improving
and that's an ongoing effort uh
hopefully more available soon can I just
say I'm so jealous that you were a good
Christian
um
I mean folks will remember that we we
had a conversation with Chris in that
question I think it was about 18 months
ago one of my favorite episodes of mlsd
so you're a very lucky man indeed yes
yes
um it's it's uh it's great to work with
Christian
um it's a it's a lot of fun it's amazing